pittsburg detect powerhouse its bird the
culinary Wonderland the city that's big
and small and approachable and amazing
all of that was part of Pittsburgh's
pitch hoping to convince ecommerce giant
Amazon to choose them as the site for a
second corporate headquarters more than
200 cities joined the competition before
the October deadline and this week
amazon narrowed the list to 20 finalists
here to discuss the search and what's at
stake for the winning cities is Wired's
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson nikka
morning this is still a pretty
formidable list I'm looking at it here
Philadelphia Pittsburgh Toronto
Washington Boston Chicago Columbus
Dallas it's a big fight still here it's
a big fight Amazon is running a reality
show the airs in every city coming to
them they've asked for all kinds of data
this is kind of an amazing process to
watch how much of it is about the city
itself and the community and how much is
just about who's gonna give us the
sweetest taxi'll I suspect that it's
mostly about the former right the cities
are competing on tax deals newark has
laid out this crazy you know seven
billion dollar tax deal I think Amazon
is gonna look at the cities and what
they said is they're gonna look at the
population side they're gonna look at
the number of highly educated workers
they're gonna look at the abilities
people to get there they're gonna look
at the transportation system my guess is
that Amazon does care a lot about taxes
it will put it into its massive
algorithm when it makes its final
decision but that the city factors will
be weighted more if you're one of these
cities what's in it for you well a lot
of prestige particularly since you'll
have one right the fact that there's
this reality show context don't say
something right it's the mayor of the
city that wins a little more status you
also get a giant headquarters you get
50,000 new jobs according to Amazon
you've got a lot of people come in there
to work they're high-tech people people
will leave Amazon spin off other
companies near the headquarters there is
a possibility that you'll be able to
create something of a tech corridor in
your city just by having Amazon there
what will you lose well or congestion
you're gonna have some of your current
tech companies you're gonna lose their
employees they're gonna be some
drawbacks and if you've given them a
massive tax package that's money you
probably could have used on I don't know
schools roads and other stuff wait and
there is now pushback in some corners is
it right to be courting these companies
so fervent
when you're diverting tax dollars to
local communities I mean this is one of
the big debates we always have when the
companies come out and say please come
here please come here because you could
do stuff with that money it's like when
you build those Super Bowl stadiums that
everybody gets all excited about and you
say wait and you look at the later
economic effect and it wasn't so great
my instinct though is that the city that
gets Amazon ten years from now is gonna
be grateful that they got Amazon what
concerns me is this weird pageant that
they're doing yeah yeah very strange and
it shows the power dynamic in America
right now we're big tech as all the
power and there's like little
corporations in general do this not just
tech companies there are other companies
that do this around the country but
there's something about this one because
Amazon has become so important it's now
one of the biggest companies in the
world and it just shows the incredible
power dynamic between Amazon and our
city government why did you Nick why do
you think Amazon decided to make this
such a hugely public pageant a couple of
reasons number one I think they're gonna
get they did the analysis and they
decided they would get a better deal if
they get the cities to openly compete
with each other they realized that part
of the process will get them a better
deal secondly if it's a closed process
information will leak it becomes harder
to manage there's something about
radical transparency that's beneficial
third I can't quite figure this out I
kind of think it's a data collection
operation right they're getting all
these cities to tell them everything
about them yeah they'll use that for the
winner and for the losers they'll figure
out their distribution they'll figure
out where they put their new factories I
mean there's gonna be a lot that Amazon
learns from this process that helps the
company right the courting process could
be lucrative in and of itself Amazon is
not stupid that is definitely true Nick
Thompson at Wired always gets a few my
friend thanks glad to be here